hi my name is Rotem aya I'm the tech
lead for Google's Android developer
relations team in order to minimize the
battery drain associated with data
transfers it's good practice to use the
big cookie model to batch and bundle
transfers using sync adapters and
eliminate unnecessary polling with
Google Cloud messaging having moved all
of your transfers into as few batches as
possible this devbyte will look at ways
to reduce the overall size of the cookie
that is to transfer as little data as
possible and drain as little battery as
possible each time we do have to do a
transfer the most fundamental way to
reduce your downloads is to download
only what you need start by using REST
API is that lets you perform filtering
on the server using parameters that
allow you to indicate when you last
update occurred or what the last items
you received were this ensures that you
only end up downloading new stuff
similarly it's good practice to reduce
bandwidth by performing any operations
likely to shrink the size of your
payload on the server techniques like
gzip compression are one solution as
this server-side reduction of image
sizes why download a wallpaper own to
shrink it into a thumbnail it's also
generally more efficient to maximize
your utilization of network connections
so rather than creating multiple
simultaneous connections to download
data or chaining multiple consecutive
get requests where possible you should
bundle these requests into a single gate
when it comes to cell radio transfers a
bazooka is more efficient than a shotgun
it's also best practice to reuse
existing network connections rather than
initiating new ones reusing connections
also allows the network to more
intelligently react to congestion and
related network data issues wireless
radios need to be active to transmit
determination and termination
acknowledgement packets associated with
server and client timeouts so it's also
good practice to closer connections when
they aren't in use rather than waiting
for these timeouts to extinguish by
themselves that said closing a
connection too early can prevent it from
being reused which then requires
additional overhead for establishing a
new connection a useful compromises to
not close the connection immediately but
to still close it before the inherent
timeout expires finally cash
aggressively you can maintain a cash
in shared storage within the external
cache directory or manager smaller cash
in your application sandbox anything
sorting the external cash can be deleted
by the system if it's running low on
space whereas you're responsible for
managing the data stored in your
application cache in a lot of cases you
can determine when you should perform in
yuan perform your next update by
inspecting the HTTP response headers of
your downloads this is particularly
useful for static for static or almost
static resources like images looking at
the header response you can determine
the time the downloaded data was changed
and when it will expire allowing you to
schedule your cache refreshes
accordingly to make your life easier
android 4.0 deuced a HTTP response cash
to the HTTP URL connection class that
handles this caching for you inspecting
headers and contacting the server only
when the cache has expired or data
doesn't exist locally throughout the
series of lights on efficient data
transfers we've explored how the cell
radio works and how the state machine
can affect the battery efficiency of
your apps and with that knowledge you
learn to analyze your network traffic
and use techniques like prefetching
batching and bundling supported by sync
adapters and Google Cloud messaging to
make your apps more efficient